over the years i've had great fun being
rude about vegetarians but today
i'm joining them i've put together a
fantastic breakfast lunch and dinner
packed with amazing tastes textures and
full-on flavor
without a bit of meat in sight i
guarantee
my ultimate vegetarian food will have
even the most committed carnivore
drooling and begging for more first up
a real treat of a meat-free breakfast
pear and crunchy granola muffins
for the perfect vegetarian lunch crispy
golden halloumi courgette and herb cakes
halloumi cheese doesn't look that tasty
but once you've got colour on it
it's really delicious and my youngest
daughter tilly joins me in the kitchen
to make a scrummy three-course veggie
dinner
that's my guilty pleasure is it really
courgette ricotta
and mint top bruschetta roasted beetroot
and thyme risotto
and for pud white chocolate and lime
mousse with crushed raspberries
wow that looks really cool these are my
ultimate vegetarian recipes
breakfast lunch and dinner
first the perfect morning treat for
vegetarians and carnivores alike
pear and crunchy granola muffins
something quite nice when you walk into
friends or family's house and you smell
a muffin being baked the flour and the
baking powder in
a nice touch of cinnamon cinnamon
muffins goes brilliantly
a pinch of salt that's really important
for the sort of overall flavor you don't
want the muffin to be too sweet
muscovado sugar that's a refined brown
sugar
really rich somewhat spicy and goes
brilliantly inside the muffin
and then my crispy granola now we're
gonna put half of this in now and save
the other half
just sprinkle on top of the muffin give
that a really good mix
in the center i'll have some fresh pear
top and tail the pears
really important to peel nothing worse
when you're trying to enjoy that muffin
and you're
negotiating with a big sliver skin of
pear
slice them round the core four sides
and slice it nice and thinly generally
muffins contain around half the fat and
sugar of cupcakes once the dry
ingredients are mixed together
you add in the wet two whole eggs
nice milk in
followed by gently melted butter
give that a good mix
[Music]
add that to your mixture just start
folding
always do it by hand muffins are
delicate dainty
little beasts don't overwork your muffin
mixture
you want that mixture to become nice and
relaxed
now the mix looks nice and creamy
your tray and your little cups
and spoon in that mixture
two-thirds full one nice generous spoon
and you can tell the mix is right
because you've got that even
distribution of the pear
running from the top to the bottom
just gently tap your tray both ends
that gets the mix all the way down so
they cook nice and evenly
take your granola now sprinkle that on
top so you've got this dual
texture spicy pear and this nice crunchy
topping
makes the muffin taste and feel a little
bit more
luxurious now into the oven at 180
for 25 minutes beauties
[Music]
they smell delicious you got that nice
crispy
top just get them out and let them cool
down
and i don't have any problems turning
vegetarian once or twice a week
when i'm having muffins like that
nice i smell amazing
[Music]
a vegetarian breakfast to put hairs on
your chest pear and crunchy granola
muffins
that is a vegetarian delight beautiful
[Music]
coming up i'll be showing you a stunning
vegetarian lunch and dinner
but first here's a more in-depth look at
the key ingredients you'll need for them
first for dinner i'm using risotto rice
risotto is a flagship classic in italian
cuisine but it's widely believed that
the spaniards introduced it to northern
italy
back in the middle ages there are three
main types
arboreal carnaroli and violoni
their ability to absorb liquid and
flavor whilst releasing lots of starch
is what makes risotto uniquely delicious
and anxious a tasty creamy and
inexpensive way to satisfy
lots of tummies without a morsel of meat
in sight
[Music]
the deep dramatic red colour of sweet
earthy beetroot makes it difficult to
outdo in terms of all round culinary
impact
but early forms of this humble root veg
were carrot shaped
and favored for their medicinal rather
than their cooking merits
today there is a veritable rainbow of
beetroot types to be enjoyed pickled
in soups grated into cakes or even
simply roasted
which is however using mine in my
amazing vegetarian main course risotto
halloumi is a firm springy salty cheese
with its roots firmly in cyprus and
grease
the betalumi is made from sheep's milk
rich in vitamins and essential nutrients
is thought to promote longevity
halloumi keeps for many months if stored
unopened in the fridge
and its high melting point makes it
brilliantly adaptable perfect for
grilling barbecuing and frying
i'll be championing this texture lending
marvel for my yummy vegetarian lunch
dish of halloumi courgette
and herb cakes
[Music]
as a chef i'm never sniffy about cooking
with vegetables because i know
that with a bit of care and attention
they can be turned into something
absolutely stunning
for my ultimate vegetarian lunch i've
got a couple of fantastic recipes
lightly fried my delicious halloumi and
courgette cakes squeeze every last bit
of flavor out of those vegetables
but first i'm preparing a simple slow
roast tomato and watercress salad
these cherry tomatoes are perfect if you
haven't got cherry tomatoes vitamins are
good or even just
big normal plump tomatoes lay the
tomatoes on the tray
and these go into the oven for about 90
minutes
if you turn the oven down really low you
can leave them in overnight
to be honest the longer you leave them
the better they taste
once you've seasoned them with salt
sprinkle over with some sugar
and the salt and sugar combined speeds
up the drying process because you want
that nice
chewy texture and then you get these
little time flowers and just
pick off the buds garlic sliced
then just spread that on now the tray
looks quite full and compact
but 90 minutes in the oven you'll see
everything shrink down
all the skins blistering and the flavor
intensifies
so nicely extra virgin olive oil that
gives a nice
earthy flavor to the tomatoes
place your tomatoes into an oven
preheated to 150 degrees c
and cook long and slow for an hour and a
half
now halloumi cakes there's something
quite exciting about halloumi cheese
it's a very firm cheese and it fries
brilliantly
[Music]
peel the carrots
[Music]
great not too finely you want that nice
texture
next courgette the secret is keep it all
grated the same put that into a sieve
[Music]
a sprinkling of salt will draw out
liquid from the vegetables
then great the halloumi halloumi cheese
doesn't look
that tasty but once you've got color on
it in the pan
it's really really delicious now
really important to squeeze out the
excess water from the veg
and we'll see all that water that needs
to come out of there
if you didn't do this it'll make your
little patties non-friable because the
whole thing
starts to separate and then mix
in with the cheese spring onions chop up
the whites and the greens now we're
going to season that with some delicious
fresh mint and fresh coriander whenever
it's vegetarian i like to put a
combination of
herbs in there tarragon parsley mint
coriander
basil and lemongrass all delicious on
their own but in tandem their flavors
play off each other
next two eggs in
give that a little mix
add the eggs to the mixture and then
finally
a couple of tablespoons of breadcrumbs
the breadcrumbs
help dry out any excess moisture
mix all the ingredients together
before you start shaping these taste the
mixture
it's really important to identify the
seasoning now if you wait until you've
cooked them
it'll be too late to adjust the
seasoning roll them to a large golf ball
shape them like a little mini burger you
could spice these up with some chili in
there
if you haven't got fresh chili chili
flakes and it's something that can be
done up
a day in advance to get your cakes firm
and ready for frying put them into the
fridge uncovered for 25 minutes
pan on get that nice and hot whilst i'm
waiting for that i'll get the
dressing ready slice of red chili seeds
and all
on an angle into shards
then chop fresh ginger season with a
sprinkle of sugar and salt
add some rice wine vinegar add a couple
of tablespoons of olive oil
to finish off some chopped coriander
[Music]
got that sweet sour spicy flavor
with my chili dressing done i can start
frying off my halloumi cakes in a hot
oiled pan
we've got a nice crisp edge
you can already start to smell that
sauteed halloumi with the
courgettes and carrots smells delicious
really important for a nice
amount of color on them as my cakes
sizzle away
i can finish off my roast tomato salad
one of my favorite
leaves has to be watercress it's cut off
stalks
[Music]
shallot rings watercress and shallot
go brilliantly well together the shallot
looks so dainty
when you open up these little ringlets
[Music]
don't forget to turn your cakes now
tomatoes whatever you don't use just jar
them
and put them in the fridge
just drop those slow cooked warm
tomatoes
over the watercress the sweetness is
incredible absolutely delicious
a little drizzle of age half smooth
vinegar
gives that tartness to the watercress
watercress is naturally peppery so
it doesn't need any pepper just a little
touch of salt
and then a light sprinkling of extra
virgin olive oil
after five minutes on a medium heat my
halloumi cakes
are ready so important to have taken out
that water
[Music]
you can see it doesn't disintegrate
and then just get your dressing take a
spoon of it and then tilt it to the side
because
i want the garnish i don't want the
juice if that does not
turn you on to become a vegetarian for
the night i honestly
don't know what will delicious
[Music]
my crispy golden halloumi courgette and
herb cakes with a sumptuous roast tomato
and watercress salad
all of the flavor with none of the meat
when i was growing up my mom was a very
very good cook so we had some great food
but it was always meat and too veg and
the veg definitely played a bit part
but the more attention you pay to
cooking vegetables the more you realise
they can easily take center stage for
all the flavor we've known the flesh
here's my ultimate vegetarian dinner
first
a hearty starter a bruschetta with
ricotta and succulent griddle courgettes
for my main i'm serving fragrant roasted
beetroot and thyme risotto
[Music]
but i'll be in trouble with the kids if
i don't do a pud
so i'm enlisting the help of my youngest
tilly to rustle up an indulgent
chocolate and lime mousse with crushed
raspberries
[Music]
so if you want wrap the chocolate start
breaking up in little bits
we're gonna make the most amazing white
chocolate mousse our first job
is to bring half of our cream up to the
boil so what kind of cream is that in
there dad
that is double cream okay so that's
gonna make a really nice rich
chocolate mousse what's your favorite
sort of chocolate is it white milk dark
um i love white and milk what's yours
i absolutely love milk chocolate ah
that's my guilty pleasure is it really
here we go cream in
so that goes in there now you can see
what's happening straight away can't you
it's melting really quickly melting
really quickly so
okay oh excuse me at least your jumper's
white so you won't spot it
yeah i've got a nice little snack for
later
in another bowl add lime zest cold cream
and whisk until it forms soft peaks
the lime cuts the sort of richness of
the cream and that starts to make
the chocolate mousse taste a little bit
lighter mmm it smells really good the
lime gives it a really nice
zingy-nessa zenith you're absolutely
right next
add to the melted chocolate mixture
because i'm whisking it's just getting
lighter
and lighter and lighter have a little
taste
mmm nice yeah the lime gives it a really
nice taste
telly i need the rest for the mousse i
need them for my tummy no
come on chocolate moves into the fridge
our next job is to separate out three
egg whites
this is where i need you at your
absolute best okay because to whip those
whites it's gonna be really tough
so we'll take it in turns 30 seconds
each okay
you go first
10 seconds gone come on tilly 15 seconds
gone
20 seconds gone come on you can do it 10
seconds to go
five four three two
one and change exit hold the ball
right no no way
[Music]
matilda you can't walk
30 seconds this puny little thing and
you come
with a big little machine gun
that's the best way of whipping up egg
whites
our contentious whipped egg whites will
make our mousse light and airy
and when they've reached soft peaks we
can gently mix in our cool white
chocolate and cream mixture
once the egg whites hit the cream the
chocolate sets
the egg whites keep the cream nice and
fluffy and you get this nice
light mousse in the bowl now i need you
to crush
some raspberries please with some fresh
mint
you can see all the juice coming out
now take your mousse wow
that looks really cool now look at that
down the bottom there little
crushed raspberry delicious now i'm
going to set that in the fridge
if you missed a count over the door
please our yummy white chocolate mousse
will take at least two hours to set
so we can crack on with our
mediterranean-inspired vegetarian
starter
griddle courgette ricotta and mint
bruschetta
for this recipe you'll need a griddle
pan an essential piece of kit
for that char grill look
cut thick slices of chapata bread
drizzle both sides with olive oil
season with a little salt and pepper and
griddle each side
until toasted then slice a couple of
courgettes
diagonally into half a centimetre thick
pieces
drizzle and coat in olive oil and season
with salt and pepper
sear on a smoking hot griddle pan in
batches until all the cagets are bar
marked on both sides
next roughly chop mint leaves and
combine with creamy
ricotta cheese spread your toasty
teapetter with dollops of minty ricotta
and top with your seared courgette super
simple
and super tasty
now we're going to make a delicious
beetroot risotto we need to get the
shallots just slice them in half and
then just
chop them like that okay okay now i've
even made a risotto
no i haven't actually schlotz please
into the pan for daddy
add a sprinkle of salt and pepper along
with a couple of crushed cloves of
garlic
once you start cooking the risotto it's
really important
to have your stock gently boiling away
if we're adding cold stock on top of the
rice all the time it just slows down the
process
generally you cook a nice wide flat pan
if you cook in a deep
pan all the rice sort of cooks at
different temperatures what stock is
that in there dad
because that's a vegetable stock yeah
because you can't have different stocks
if it's more vegetarian can you
have chicken stock i made that mistake
once putting beef stock in a vegetarian
soup
no i didn't matilda are you sure i'm
positive i'm joking
fry off the time how nice does that
smell it smells
delicious rice in that's a bit of a
different rice
this is alborrio rice it's a perfect
rice for risotto
now it's really important to sear the
rice
if we just put the stocking without
sweating off the rice it goes all
starchy
so keep on stirring for daddy it's just
going to make a formula
no flambe on the risotto
to go with our deep red beet root theme
i'm adding red wine
followed by the first ladle of stock to
get things started
now we're off wow it's giving it a
cloudy sort of look
what's happening to the stock the stock
is reducing down and the rice is sucking
it
in that's right so the rice is actually
getting nice and plump
one of risotto is live when it's like
this now we can't stop cooking there we
have to kill it all the way
okay ready for the next ladle i'm ready
good girl here we go
ladle in so we have to make this for
literally
20 25 minutes and we're nursing it all
the way
beetroots peel them rub them a little
bit of salt
and sugar yeah and a little bit of aged
balsamic vinegar in there
roasted them i'm gonna grate my parmesan
how's that rice doing the rice is doing
good now
that is exactly where we want to be now
look look at that nice glossy
textured rice so beetroot i want you to
put
two thirds of beetroot in there for me
saving one third for the top
good sprinkle the parmesan in there for
me please all over
nice it's like it's snowing again and
then
we're just gonna get some nice butter in
there the butter gives the risotto a
really nice gloss
look at that beautiful let that come
down let it come down first
all right get your spoon in there now
daddy beautifully there you go
good wonderful shake it risotto should
be like lava
it just flows out
and then the rest of the beetroot on top
and then finish
some extra virgin olive oil on top
i'll pick up the bruschetta you take
that to the table
okay let's go danny
this is my ultimate vegetarian dinner
delicious courgette ricotta and mint
top bruschetta an anxious roasted
beetroot and thyme risotto
and for put an indulgent white chocolate
and lime mousse with fresh crushed
raspberries
phoebe jack mum a delicious
non-meat feast that will have
vegetarians and carnivores
fighting for seconds tonight is
vegetarian night meg how is it
really tasty i love it i really liked
making the risotto
and we had fun so where's holly disco
discus aren't very nice they hurt your
ears
cheers no meat vegetarian
vegetarians there are loads more great
home cooking recipes on my app
cook with me you can find it in the app
store good luck